متى كانت المرة الأولى التي قابلت فيها فلاديمير
بوتين ،
قابلت فلاديمير بوتين لأول مرة عندما
كان نائب عمدة سانت بطرسبرغ
وكان يشغل منصب نائب
عمدة الإصلاحي أناتولي
تشاك وأتذكر أن هذا الرجل كان يقف في
الزاوية بدا بعيدًا قليلاً  من
المكان وذهبت إليه وقلت
مرحبًا وقال مرحبًا لم نتحدث
كثيرًا ولا أتذكر الكثير مما
قيل
ثم
في يوليو من عام 2001 عندما كنت مع
الرئيس بوش في
سلوفينيا ونظرت  صعودًا وهنا جاءت السلحفاة
الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين وفكرت يا
إلهي ، أتذكر الآن أنه نفس
الرجل ،
لذلك عندما التقيت به أه
كمستشار للأمن القومي لأول
مرة ما كان انطباعك الأول
عنه كرجل دولة
ظننت أنه في تلك اللحظة الأولى
عندما التقينا به مع الرئيس بوش
لأول مرة بدا أنه يبدو
خجولًا بعض الشيء ومتحفظًا بعض الشيء ،
إنه يمشي مثل رياضي ،
هناك حضور مؤكد له وهو
يفرز.  و لكن عندما بدأت
في الحديث معه لم ينظر إليك
في عينيك ، بدا
قلقا بعض الشيء ربما حول مقابلة
رئيس الولايات المتحدة
للمرة الأولى وغني عن القول إنه ذهب
بسرعة كبيرة من
خجول  أن تكون واثقًا من الغرور إلى الجنون الشديد ،
لكن في المرات القليلة الأولى
اعتقدت أنه كان في الواقع قليلًا أه
يفتقر إلى الثقة لدي إحساس
بأن
بوتين قد أطلق بعض الأشياء
التي لم يكن ينوي تحريكها
وربما هناك
أأ  إعادة التفكير في موسكو حول ما
تم تحقيقه من خلال هذا التراكم الهائل من خلال
كل هذه التهديدات من خلال
التدريبات التهديدية التي حدثت من
خلال السرد الذي تم إنشاؤه
في الصحافة الروسية وفي أماكن أخرى
حول المخاطر التي يتعرض لها السكان الناطقون بالروسية
في
الجزء الشرقي من
أوكرانيا يمثل تراكمًا كبيرًا بشكل فظيع
ويتساءل المرء عما إذا كان قد قلل من تقدير
الناتو
لرد الفعل الذي قد يجلب معه
التفكير في أنه يمكن أن يخيف
ربما حتى الأوكرانيين إلى شيء
أكثر
سنرى كيف هذا آه كيف سيظهر
هذا ولكن آمل أن يفعل شيئًا آخر
وهو تذكيرنا
بأنه بقدر ما نريد الانتقال
من الهيدروكربونات لدعم سياسة المناخ
إذا استغرق هذا
الانتقال  مكان وتركنا خارجا
لا يسمح للولايات المتحدة
بالاستفادة من أصولها الهائلة في
النفط والغاز سنقوم بتسليم بطاقة النفط إلى
فلاديمير بوتين
لكم.